i'll be very strong um jordan peterson
as well
i have the great privilege today of
talking with
ayan jerzy ali um
she's one of my heroes i guess that's
the case ever since i read her book
recently how many dropped on a video by
and
uh joe rogan um jordan peterson he does
like we'll be honest we'll be giving him
the benefit of doubt but he's starting
to sound like a closet islamophobe i'm
so sorry and then
people that follow the more radical
version of the religion that wants to
convert people to
discuss it to acknowledge it and to
automatically classify any discussion of
it
as islamophobic and that i've seen this
labeled this this label put on you
that you are islamophobic he's made
certain statements about islam which he
has no knowledge about
and then joe rogan invites this woman
the assertion that islam is a religion
of peace if they want to believe that
islam is a religion of peace let's let's
say it's a long let's come
let's do it along with him it's as if
he's saying you know what
why don't you say the things i can't let
me invite you that's what it is
i can't see it but i'm you're my guest
you know no one can say nothing you know
i invited a guest you know i didn't tell
her to say that
you know come on let's not let's not
fall around here it's very simple what
you're doing
you can invite anyone muhammad hijab
hamzazzo says there's so many people
that you can invite that could come and
talk about islam but that's not going to
be good for you you don't like that
so the thing is to invite people like
her who's an outright and she's alive
she's alive she lied about her whole
life whole story you know and she's
there coming and she's lying and saying
you know that she's talking about forced
uh that in islam that
we're allowed to you know she's talking
about dawah and you know we can force
people to accept
they have to accept islam by the sword
this is the biggest myth ever you know
there's specific verses in the quran in
surah baqarah verse 2 5 6
you know very clearly islam islam you
cannot force anyone to
their your religion is simple the
expansion of the
islamic empire does not mean there was
forced conversions
yeah it's the the empire expanding
doesn't mean you know people being
forced to accept islam
you know so people have this thinking
that oh yeah islamic empire expanded and
they're
converting people by the swords it's not
like that it's as simple as that to you
your religion to me mine
i'm i can convey but i can't force and
we have many examples we have many
examples in history where
individuals could have forced a slave
where he
um he he he said look if only you
accepted islam
you know et cetera so you have many
examples where people were given the
chance to accept islam
but yeah there's an outright liar and
yeah and in charleston hopefully she'll
debate mohammed hijab one day
uh she touched upon it gabriel i don't
know if you want to touch punish ali she
in her talk with joe rogan she touched
upon
and we cover this all the i mean we've
covered this so many times but she
mentioned i believe
the forced marriage honor killings
you as a as a young woman
were going to be forced into an arranged
marriage and this is what
made you flee and and head to europe and
wind up in holland correct that's
correct had he
been with us earlier he might have taken
this initiative to force me into
marriage at the age of 15
16 17.
you guys uh you get kind of like this is
like an old
old old record you know that just keeps
playing and you get you know tired of
hearing this
these uh it goes from someone being
ignorant who just certainly sincerely
doesn't know but then somebody who
obviously
knows the truth and then even her uh
community there called her out on that
you know
so what do you say for the for the
person who sincerely maybe just uh
bit on this yeah and how would you
respond for this honor killing forced
marriages
right right i think i think sincerity is
is the key here
and you can defer and you can have you
know issues whatever
whatever it is you know even with jordan
peterson you know i was reading his book
he's a smart guy man you know but he's
really disappointing because he should
know better
on the academic approach of verifying
information he's an academician
right so he's being academically
dishonest in the statements that he's
making you're talking about jordan
peterson now
jordan peterson yeah yeah i'm talking
about drawing pieces you just wanted to
make that point right because
he's very smart guys a very smart man
here you understand that it's not enough
to just be smart
you have to be also honest okay and you
have to
if you're doing so much research you
know how how much
academic integrity is important and
checking and verifying information
that is the whole you know foundation of
islam
hadith the science of verifying hadith
and knowledge and information is
based on reliability on
you know academic uh checking of who
says what
who is this person are they qualified to
actually relate this information
it's a huge huge science that what's the
objective
to just make sure that honesty is is
there when you're passing on information
right why so that
obviously you're not going to misguide
people with the wrong things with
this woman may allah guide her
obviously the enemies of islam have been
using these type of tactics from the
time of the prophet
and subhanallah i mean i was today i was
teaching a class on
and we were mentioning the incident of
the person who came and asked the
prophet saws
about the statement in the quran
o sister right referring to mary
malaysia
right and until today bro the process
doesn't explain very much like you know
like we said
this is how the you they used to refer
to humble people pious people
as for their ancestors and so on you
know we are venus
and so on till today bro you'll find
this argument on the
answering islam website that oh
crosstalk
didn't know that you know who's the two
sisters
aarons or mary's or you know i mean it's
just
ridiculous so these all these uh forced
marriages for
conversions uh by the sword and so on
they keep it's been refuted it's been
academically
approached and shown and so on
and i'm not denying that there was in
the history of islam
in some cases no doubt certain rulers
and leaders who did force converse there
are some
okay there's no doubt about it it's not
that that's not the question the
question is does
islam preach that is that the
theory of islam this is what's the way
as to what some person did
in this century that century i mean that
you can point to every single
nation and religion there's always gonna
be certain bad apples that interpreted
things and did things their whole way
now you have the for example the
hashashi on
where the word assassin comes from right
and how and
was directed his attacks towards them
actually you know
but these were claiming to be muslims
who right were doing all kinds of
evil things people will do a lot of
things okay
bottom line is what does islam
preach what does quran preach what does
the sunnah preach
this is what we ask the world to look at
alright
this is what we ask the world to look at
holly